i'm missy peregrine keep watching e.t
canada
you will not throw a double back without
training at first haley
over my dead body little cpr might do
you good
haley
she's crazy yeah we had to train for
about four months
um six hours a day five days a week
it was crazy it was really intense and
then we had to try to keep training
while we were filming the movies that
didn't even include
like filming so for about six months i
mean we trained
four months really hardcore and then the
other two months i mean i tried to do
things but it was really
so busy that it was hard to do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was such a difficult thing to do and
to learn and to master first of all you
can't even master it takes
years and years and years to do anything
but it was so frustrating because you
one day you could do 100 turns like
perfect turns and you could balance and
everything's great the next day you
can't do anything and you're like what
i was so good yesterday so it was just
it was a lot of like it was really tough
emotionally and mentally just
as well as physical it was really crazy
haley graham
has come out of retirement to train with
us you've really gotten skinny
fat
we are so not enemies in real life we
are such good friends
i don't i wouldn't have been able to do
anything without her training
the filming i mean we've come so close
we actually after the film
we went on a trip we went uh back to
vancouver where i grew up and then we
both went to montreal
and went to toronto and then we came
back here but it was like such an
amazing trip it was so nice
working on a film and doing publicity
and doing that stuff can be really
stressful sometimes you know and it's
it can be intimidating and scary but the
fact that we get along so well and we
can joke around and
take it lily is probably the best thing
for us i mean it definitely
makes me feel better about it so i love
working with her